bandera rojas ondean en el estado de
minas gerais y la Euforia marca la
llegada del candidato izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva
a solo una semana de la vuelta
presidencial definitiva el ex presidente
Hace un contundente llamado a los
indecisos
[Música]
quería decirles que deben visitar a
todos los compañeros que saben que no
votaron y pedir un voto para nosotros
pedir un voto para la democracia pedir
un voto contra el fascismo y pedir un
voto para que el pueblo brasileño vuelva
a ser respetado
mientras muchos aún dudan de su voto
otros son sus seguidores hace años ven
en la imagen de Lula la del ex
sindicalista y obrero una nueva
oportunidad para ser representados
Esta foto es de 1984 Tiene 38 años esta
foto Soy yo con Lula representa
Esperanza amor unidad que es lo que
significa Lula para nosotros
necesitamos más amor y menos odio
en una campaña marcada por las noticias
falsas y los ataques cruzados los
candidatos y sus seguidores hacen hasta
lo imposible para convencer a los
últimos adeptos
más al sur en Río de Janeiro sus
simpatizantes organizaron todo un
carnaval ante la creciente incertidumbre
del resultado final entre bailes música
y comparsas movimientos sociales afines
a Lula celebran su camino hacia el
palacio del plan alto
se prevé unos resultados apretados el 30
de octubre la más reciente encuesta de
datafoya muestra Lula como ganador
llevándose un 49% de los votos frente al
45 de Yair bolsonaro una cifra que
genera dudas ante las cerradas
predicciones de la primera vuelta